Robert Griffin the third Ravens
quarterback signed a two-year contract
extension with Ravens this morning and
he joins us now
how are you RG three hey great to get to
talk to you again how you been I'm I'm
doing well I think I still have your
shoes from the combine here on my desk
mark when you ran the 40 when's the last
time you ran a time 240 this offseason
would you run for 39 well at the time on
I ran for three seven they they adjusted
back back but yeah I've been down that
longer Ito's down to Miami trained and
decided to get on the flat precise and
then look clocking it in for three
dollars so I'm pretty excited about that
do you think you're faster than Kyler
Murray I don't know you know let them be
great let him be who he is
you know football the bass goes but I
can tell you one thing I'm not as shifty
as caller garlic and what advice would
you give him because you had the high
highest of highs that rookie year you
got injured a couple of times so what
advice would you give him going into the
NFL from a running perspective I was
more fearless when it came to taking on
hits and in diving in their calls in
college to get down and protect himself
in college and you know part of that is
no one can tackle it's so fast and it's
so shifty he kind of just you know
what's around everybody but the advice I
give them is in the throws just continue
to do what he did in college
make sure he gets down to the more some
of those big hits and elongate his
career it's something that I've learned
over the past couple years and have been
able to showcase and then we'll showcase
lies here two pieces of Baltimore and
then you know hopefully in the future
we'll continue to showcase uh after I
get another an opportunity to you know
the stars
okay but explain to me why were you
macho out there taking on these
defenders I mean you know it's something
that I have to you know help my man LJ
with you know continuing to understand
that you know there's not that these
guys that are bigger faster and stronger
is that they're just the best in the
world so take all the best players in
college the moment to the NFL and now
the field smaller because the hashes are
closer to get closer together so it's
good to make sure you understand that
yes you can be super good but you also
have to be Superman and slide in berms
and make sure you don't take those those
big hurts and you know I look at Lamar
Jackson and he's the future there but
you're a competitor how do you go to
work knowing that your job is really to
get him prepared to go into battle as
opposed to somebody doing that for you
yes the thing that that makes the most
sense for me when it comes to that is I
have to you know make sure I'm ready to
go
and I think in the process of doing that
I'll be able to support out there if I
show up and I'm a pro if I show up and I
study the way I'm supposed to study and
I work the way I'm supposed to work to
ensure that I'm ready to play anytime
I'm called upon effect on LJ and will
help him be able to study like he's
supposed to study work how he's supposed
to work and be ready to play you know
until the organization and talk to her
and they know that I'm not going to be
I'm gonna be on a percent supportive of
him and I want him to be the future here
in Baltimore and at the same time I'll
continue to work extremely hard be a
competitor and try to make him better
every single day and at the same time
it'll make me better and give me an
opportunity to go out and
get back to where I want to be a you
know it's a tough process having to
start all the way over with the leverage
but you know I'm in the middle of that
and you know I'm moving on to CP 2 and
got a race so I'm excited about the
future your head coach John Harbaugh
quoted as saying that the Browns have
the most talent in the division do you
think he really believes that with coach
Harbaugh I think he I think he says what
he believes but I think the guys in our
locker room understand exactly what he's
saying it's it's not that he's saying
they're a better team than we are it's
just on paper they might have their name
on paper that might have more excitement
all Network said it best they still got
to come to the defending champs in the
north and take it from us so when we get
on the field it's more about who's the
better team not whom that has per se
more star power or more talent he's
Robert Griffin the third you know that
we have one of the den it's one of the
guys on my show he refers to you well
this is what he said he accidentally
said this years ago when you were at
Baylor and one of the Heisman Trophy
candidates Robert Griffith jr. the third
so he got your name wrong twice its
Robert Griffith jr. the third and I'm
actually notoriously Jay Gruden uses my
name wrong every day a third and not a
lot of people know that because they
know the acronym RG 3 and I'm ok it
doesn't bother ya man
call me Robert vs. jr. the third that's
one heck of an eye and I got a Cleveland
Browns Jersey made up that says Griffin
Griffith jr. the third on the back so
it's it's one of a kind
the last the junior and the third yeah
yeah good stuff hey congrats on signing
the contract extension and good luck
this upcoming season we appreciate it
no and that's Robert Griffith jr. the
third for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]